una vez más el mar Mediterráneo ha sido
testigo de otra tragedia humanitaria con
la muerte de más de 70 migrantes
ilegales la mayoría sirios y líbaneses
que viajaban en una embarcación ilegal
con rumba Europa que naufragó ayer en
las costas sirias de tartus se trata del
viaje más mortífero hasta la fecha aquí
en el Líbano después de que hace cuatro
meses en un naufragio similar decenas de
libaneses desaparecieran en la mar y no
fueran encontrados hasta hace un mes el
Líbano se ha convertido en la nueva ruta
de la emigración ilegal a Europa de
cientos de libaneses desesperados
refugiados sirios y palestinos que
malviven en este país ante la tremenda
crisis económica desde hace unos años a
medida que se ha ido deteriorando la
situación económica que ha llevado más
del 80% de la población libanesa a vivir
bajo el umbral de la pobreza y la moneda
local a evaluarse hasta el 200% frente
al Dólar las ciudades portuarias de
trípoli y la vecina car se han
convertido en la puerta de salida de
estas embarcaciones que se dirigen a
chipre que es el lugar más cercano del
Líbano a Europa o a las costas de Italia
cargado de migrantes que esperan una
vida mejor